bonjour à tous Nous sommes repartis pour
l'avant-dernière ronde du tata style et
aujourd'hui je suis en compagnie de
Fatou l'invité surprise deux fois
l'invité surprise en fait Fatou parce
que
tu avais décrit comme tel alors j'ai
tisais un petit peu mais le chat hier
n'était pas dupe et s'attendait à te
voir tu vas bien Fatou ça va très bien
bonjour tout le monde c'est ça plus trop
de surprise mais
mais bon c'était encore moi mais content
d'être là quoi content d'être là de
streamer ce bel événement
et puis en ta compagnie
oui bah c'est vrai que c'est assez sympa
de voir ces parties de très haut niveau
hier j'étais avec avec Laurent
Freyssinet comme tu le sais j'ai trouvé
que les parties étaient un peu chiante
un peu molle
surtout pour un Breton que je suis j'ai
une une éducation de joueurs d'attaque
on va dire d'un point de vue échiquier
enfin tout et c'était hyper intéressant
justement dans des positions que
j'affectionnais pas trop bah de voir les
analyses de Laurent qui excellait dans
ces positions là avec des plans vraiment
qui étaient des fois assez défensif il
prenait assez régulièrement la position
de de wesleo contre Magnus et il
arrivait à jouer des coups pour tenir la
position sans l'affaiblir il y a eu pas
mal de moments intéressants c'est aussi
dans la finale de cavalier entre Abdou
et guéri qu'il y a eu des bons échanges
je trouverai donc faire regarder en
différé c'est le moment là j'ai appris
pas mal de choses dans ces positions je
suis pas forcément à l'aise définir là
c'est plate ou avec des joueurs de ma
catégorie hello on se met souvent
d'accord Fatou pour pour faire nul en se
disant bon allez ça a l'air nul on va
faire nul et en fait il y a quand même
des choses à la gratter un même caresser
il a poussé hier Wesley sceaux c'était
assez impressionnant
il y a toujours des substivités
donc je cherche toujours jusqu'au bout
je doute toujours bien sûr bien sûr non
mais c'est normal quand je te dis qu'on
s'accorde pour la nul c'est pas toujours
vrai des fois il y a des moments doute
mais quand même on a pas le niveau
technique
de Magnus par exemple ni de wesleo pour
poser des problèmes comme il l'a fait
hier à wesleo qui a bien répondu
évidemment et les parties elles vont
elles vont commencer quasiment tout de
suite sachez-le alors toujours pareil ça
commence à 14h à weycanzey donc le tata
style des marac à 14h et à 14h15 les
coups vont apparaître
on peut faire tout parler des rencontres
du jour
voilà est-ce que tu as une rencontre
préférée déjà aujourd'hui un match que
tu veux particulièrement suivre
ou deux tu as le droit à deux il y a pas
de question piège ici
à part tu sais que je suis un peu fan du
moralement
qui est qui finalement traîne un petit
peu en fin de peloton d'autant plus
qu'il a eu de belles opportunités et
qu'il a plutôt joué correctement dans ce
tournoi et il est mal payé il est mal
payé il a raté plusieurs finales ou
plusieurs avantages mais il arrive à
pousser et Laurent parlait en grand bien
de Vincent Kemer hier en disant bah
c'était l'avenir de réussir à prendre
l'avantage et à pousser les joueurs
qu'il rencontre dans ce tournoi les
genre très fort qu'il rencontre c'est
des grosses grosses performances grosse
performance mais les papiers il est pas
payé énorme exactement bah il nous avait
montré un très beau visage à tout faire
et moi lorsqu'on commentait champion du
monde de rapides champion du monde de
Blitz il avait été assez impériale et il
avait failli inquiéter Magnus Magnus
toujours plus régulier alors aujourd'hui
il y aura Magnus justement avec les
pièces blanches on le voit là sur le
stream qui sera opposé au petit chouchou
on va dire c'est le numéro 2 de stouf le
petit Prague le petit Prague pas si en
forme que ça dans le tournoi il avait
bien commencé là ça commence à se
déliter on va dire peut-être ça plus
mauvaise partie hier contre avec les
Blancs contre Mac 12 loup max doudou
pardon que sous appel macdoslo voilà
qu'est-ce que tu en penses de ce match
là
est-ce que tu as une idée
pas tout est-ce que tu parierais plutôt
la victoire de Magnus la nul de Prague
ou la grosse cote le gain le gain de
Prague
allez va pour une nulle d'accord tu
joueras
voilà en bon parieur je dirais plutôt la
victoire de Magnus sans faire de cotes à
Fatou évidemment
non mais bon déjà Magnus il a bien
poussé hier ça doit être dur pour PRAP
psychologiquement même s'il doit être
super content à la fois de jouer Magnus
mais avec les pièces noires il va se
faire un peu un peu poussé normalement
et on a un gros match aussi avec abdousa
torov contre Wesley Sow
ben ouais c'est ça va essayer je pense
de pousser dans cette partie en tout cas
c'est ce que j'espère pour le spectacle
puisqu'il peut encore revenir où est-ce
les sceaux je rappelle qu'au niveau du
du classement puisque puisque je l'ai là
on a Wesley soki et quatrième donc on a
abusa j'ai plus les
j'aimerais bien virer ça tiens comment
je fais pour virer ça je sais pas ce que
j'ai mis encore mais j'ai encore mis un
truc incroyable si le roi de la
technique j'ai plus les scores
il y a pas moyen d'avoir le tableau en
grand non plus
ah bah en fait il faudrait que je
demande à Vanessa si on peut avoir si on
peut voir le tableau des scores le
mais il faudrait que je le demande en
anglais alors je sais que
board déjà c'est pas mal
Vanessa canaya the scorbob please voilà
ce que je peux faire en anglais bien sûr
je connais je connais bien sûr le fait
que Abdou il a un demi point d'avance
sur un niche gueri et un point sur
Magnus et Wesley sceaux mais
je sais j'ai fait plaisir et là c'est
qu'une phrase donc j'ai un potentiel en
anglais pour amuser le chat qui est
assez incroyable je pense Fatou oui oui
alors si vous saviez ce que nous on
s'est connecté depuis un quart d'heure
déjà et puis j'ai eu l'occasion de voir
Kevin de discuter avec notre notre haute
tu es privilégié Fatou
un gros spectacle vous louper quelque
chose mais c'est proposé de faire ça sur
sa chaîne plus souvent donc n'hésitez
pas à libérer
éventuellement
j'ai l'impression tu es un peu romancé
les choses tu m'as suggéré le fait de
faire un peu plus de stream en anglais
pendant des streams français voilà pour
que les gens puissent progresser en
anglais à mon contact c'était un petit
peu ça l'idée j'ai l'impression bon
voilà alors que le mot te propose plutôt
la chaîne Youtube chascom mais en
français voilà faut pas hésiter pour
faire la pub pour la chaîne Youtube
aussi en anglais qu'on peut aller voir
quand bilingue comme moi par exemple
du coup pour l'instant en tout cas j'ai
beau avoir fait l'effort de parler
anglais ça n'a pas marché donc j'ai
plutôt demandé le petit scoreboard via
un petit message
[Musique]
sur zoom donc maintenant vous savez
tout je ne m'appelle pas Fatou désolé je
le mites est tombé
mais bonjour quand même
on me dit donc c'est super parce que
Robin stride me dit que les parties sont
bien commencés ah oui mais en fait c'est
vrai qu'on a pas la caméra mais je me
suis mis donc sur la partie de Magnus
vous savez qu'on aime bien suivre Magnus
et je viens de m'apercevoir que alors il
est possible que Magnus ne soit pas là
que Manu se soit pas là j'ai
l'impression qu'on va avoir peut-être
plus d'informations alors là je peux
avoir le scoreboard c'est un petit peu
en décalé pour l'instant
ah bah finalement j'ai rien eu après
ça fait alors maintenant j'aimerais bien
plutôt ok le scorboard il est not
working comme on dit dans le jargon donc
ça veut dire qu'il veut pas venir OK
et je vais demander plutôt
la caméra de Magnus voilà
que j'ai failli appeler maintenu voilà
et du coup est-ce qu'on a d'autres
parties du coup qui sont comment on a
d'autres parties on a d'autres parties
parce que pour l'instant regarder un
échiquier qui n'avait pas démarré mais
on racontait un petit peu notre Life et
c'est important aussi donc
exactement et alors là je peux te dire
que le riz on a une de mes ouvertures
préférées
et je suis content d'avoir à ce niveau
là quand même c'est Abdou sa torrent il
a joué un gambida m'a accepté on va tout
de suite remontrer le début donc des cas
des cinq gambidables avec C4 l'idée
c'est que normalement
les Noirs ne doivent pas prendre parce
qu'ils vont lâcher les centres et le
pion va être repris le rythme
normalement ça se fait pas
en fait ça se fait quand même voilà
voilà tout l'histoire parce que il y a
des idées que sur E4 finalement les
Noirs jouent E5 c'est-à-dire je donne le
son dans un premier temps mais pour
mieux le récupérer
du coup pour tout le monde tous les
chats le principe du Grand c'est
donner un pion ou parfois même deux
contre de l'espace ou de l'activité donc
là l'idée c'est de prendre le centre
juste derrière et pouvoir peut-être
développer plus facilement ses pièces et
quand même avoir l'idée de récupérer
l'option
donc tu n'es pas forte quand structure
d'option tu es forte aussi en Gambie et
tu nous parlais en substance de l'avance
de développement
et du coup j'ai demandé à Vanessa la
femme de Magnus mais j'ai le droit de la
cam de Vincent Kemer peut-être qu'elle a
fait ce petit cadeau
que au niveau de du joueur allemand
merci
ok donc E4 c'est une des grandes
variantes c'est la variante trash et on
a vu ça pas plus tard qu'hier dans
quelle partie on a vu ça rappelait le
mois dans le chat ceux qui ont suivi
hier j'ai un trou j'ai un trou je le
confesse mais on a vu la variante avec
un tiers dites-moi quel mémoire de
poisson rouge même une pièce Gambie
Halloween non kovich tu as raison voilà
c'est tout à fait plaisir alors que
robinside essaie de nous détourner de
nos commentaires échiquins et commence à
nous dire qu'un gros duel capillaire
entre Fab Fabiano Caruana et Vincent
Kemer merci Robinson d'essayer de
commencer voilà alors très variable on
m'a dit ça j'essaie de parler pourtant
devant mon micro au maximum je vous le
dis je pense que le fait passer par zoom
change des choses parce que j'avais déjà
eu cette remarque ce que j'ai micro un
petit peu particulier qui normalement
permet d'avoir un bon son mais il faut
que je reste vraiment devant le micro je
vais le rapprocher les germes peut-être
que ça sera un petit peu mieux je ferai
attention c'est promis en tout cas ça
c'est la magie du zoom alors le 4
grandes lignes avec E5 on l'a vu hier
est-ce que quelqu'un on a parlé Guy
voilà c'est guérir il y a que Robinson
qui suit enfin tout dans le chat
j'espère que le chat va se réveiller en
tout cas E45 la classique donc a vu hier
puisque avec
je reviens sur la partie d'hier Abdou
avait déjà mis en place son gambidam
accepté variant de trash de guéri E4 E5
cavalier F3 et le plus rare ou BK que je
connaissais assez mal ici qui a pour but
d'aplanir un petit peu le jeu donc
aujourd'hui nouvelle tentative de Gambie
d'un accepter de la part d'adoussa torov
mais où est-ce que a joué l'autre
variante si vous voulez chapitre 1 E4 la
grosse baston avec E5 ça part en V et
deuxième variante plus positionnelle on
joue cavalier F3 je ne veux pas me
prendre 5 alors
et j'aimerais jouer j'aimerais jouer au
Cap quand même donc les Noirs cavalier
F6 tu m'empêches de jouer E5 je
t'empêche de jouer au 4 c'est normal
c'est la grande théorie de cette
position et du coup les Blancs jouent
modestement E3 pour venir récupérer le
pion et avoir l'avance de développement
dont tu nous parlais dans les Gambie en
général et le fait d'avoir le très haut
de départ le tempo d'avance m'a permis
au blanc ici sans avoir donné de pions
réellement en puisqu'il le récupère
après E6 je vous prends ces quatre bah
ils ont l'avance de développement dont
tu nous parlais plus l'espace au centre
donc ils sont contents les blancs
exactement et on peut se demander quelle
est l'urgence de la position avec les
noirs
et ben dans cette position la priorité
c'est de récupérer le centre mais on a
plus cette poussée au 5 donc ça c'est
assez facile le riz c'est assez
pédagogique comme ouverture si on donne
le centre on doit le récupérer c'est 5 a
été joué il y a une question
intéressante et ce qui est-ce qu'on peut
se raccrocher au pion
c'est pas conseillé alors toi tu voulais
sur 3 essaie de faire un B5 par exemple
voilà je suppose que c'est ça alors du
coup
c'est sur la diagonale du fou blanc mon
fou doit absolument sortir sinon il est
complètement coincé ici et c'est
malheureux alors du coup il faut que
j'entreprenne quelque chose les ruptures
classiques que vous devez absolument
connaître dans cette position c'est soit
B3 soit à 4 ou les deux voilà on va
cumuler ces ruptures la séquence
classique c'est A4
je ne peux pas faire à 6 vous voyez donc
je fais C6 pour défendre les pions avec
les pions je prends
puis on prend
et là le riz tu dois connaître je pense
la thématique
et du coup on va faire très mal on va
faire la rupture avec B3 et je fais mal
aux deux pions
sur pion prend B3 je peux prendre ici en
B5 sur chaque bon c'est la cata je crois
c'est vraiment la marque
sont pas développés tout à fait et ça
fait des trous de partout on peut pas
partir plus comme ça donc en général
c'est ça
[Musique]
si on le donne vaut mieux pas s'y
raccrocher faut toujours voir aux échecs
chercher un équilibre donc donner
quelque chose contre autre chose et
parfois on vous accrochez au matériel
mais si c'est pour perdre l'espace le
temps
autre chose c'est pas possible donc en
fait faut jauger et là le principe du
Gambier c'est que non si on laisse on
s'y accroche pas
après faut connaître il faut connaître
impossible les suites les ruptures dont
voilà faut que tu gardes les idées cette
idée de rupture en tête et du coup tu
verras que c'est ça devient mauvais de
se raccrocher au plus
et Fatou il y a Ziko ce qui nous dit
mais pourquoi digne allez s'enterrer à
weycanzé faire ce tournoi alors qu'il a
prochainement un match de championnat du
monde
dès le début avril contre nepomatchi en
fait les joueurs ils ont besoin pour moi
d'être dans le rythme quand même digne
il avait envie
d'avoir du temps de jeu donc je trouve
que c'est assez légitime qu'il y
participe oui c'est vrai ce que tu dis
au niveau des ouvertures je sais pas
comment il gère il a dit que globalement
il allait jouer comme si de rien n'était
est-ce que c'est de l'info ou de l'intox
je ne sais pas donc il peut être un
petit peu gêné au niveau ouverture mais
ces joueurs là à 2800 ils ont une Range
monumentale d'ouverture à disposition
donc il va avoir du temps de jeu surtout
le reste et de voir varier un peu plus
ses ouvertures pour moi ça colle je
trouve qu'il a fait le bon choix d'être
de venir ici c'est un super tournoi
c'est un joueur avant les tournois dans
le monde du sport ben on doit avoir les
gros tournois on doit jouer voilà je
sais pas ce que tu en penses un fatum
mais ça me paraît assez logique la
démarche de
les joueurs qu'on a envie de jouer donc
pourquoi ne pas le faire si la location
[Musique]
ça fait sens et puis les échecs c'est du
bluff aussi est-ce que je vais jouer la
même chose est-ce que non sur quoi tu
vas te préparer bon tu peux retrouver à
ce niveau comme dit Kévin tout est
possible ils connaissent tellement de
choses donc
c'est pas forcément une prise de risque
et salut à toi Néandertal ça nous fait
plaisir de te retrouver sur sur ce
stream ainsi que tous les autres qui
nous ont rejoints et on va continuer un
petit peu
ce gamin m'acceptait
et bon voilà
c'est un début Réty que nous raconte on
est endertale il a bien reconnu le
Gambie d'un accepté je suis sûr
Néandertal du coup l'urgence de la
position on l'avait pas dit mais c'est
évidemment de taper le centre donc c'est
5 puisqu'on peut plus faire E5
petit rock et là le coup caractéristique
du gambidam OUI OUI ah si c'est un très
bon coup pour faire B5 et placer le fou
en B7 puisque le fou c'est une des moins
bonne pièce des Noirs puisqu'il est
bloqué par ce pion et aussi sur la diago
donc
occupez-vous de vos moins bonnes pièces
dans les débuts sinon vous risquez
d'avoir des problèmes sur le long terme
et dire j'ai rien pu faire avec cette
pièce durant toute la partie solutionner
vos problèmes directement essayer de
trouver un plan le jeu harmonieux pour
toutes vos pièces alors ça serait quoi
le plan harmonieux bah voilà mon
cavalier peut aller en 17 ou C6 mon fond
en E7 et D6 petit rock et le fond en B7
c'est la classique du gambidamax accepté
c'est à dire que c'est un peu toujours
la même chose en terme de développement
mais on peut s'adapter à un kd7 kss6 ou
7 ou 6 c'est les petits changements de
rien du tout mais qu'ils vont amener des
positions un petit peu différentes quand
même
et là franchement on laisse les sauts il
a pas fait un choix très rigolo il a
joué des Français 5 en tige-le de
westleso anti je dois laisser soit que
se dépenser 5 dans le Gambie d'un
accepté
qu'est-ce que tu en penses Lorie
je sais pas je sais pas ce que je dois
en penser
en fait
il veut échanger dame dès le début
je pense pas parce que les blancs sont
toujours un petit peu mieux dans ses
positions là je les ai jouées je t'ai
parlé de ma technique qui est un peu
rudimentaire la technique des joueurs
bretons est un peu rudimentaire et sur
le net on m'a déjà joué ça on m'a
échangédames mais après on m'a fait
souffrir donc c'est quand même un petit
peu dangereux va falloir faire un petit
peu attention dans le début chez
abdosadora par contre il est probable
comme tu le dis kadoussa Torah va
défendre bien et qu'un équilibre arrive
assez tôt dans le jeu mais je crois pas
que Wesley Sow il joue il a les blancs
il joue le numéro 1 du tournoi il peut y
coller et revenir complètement dans le
tournoi ben on y va quoi enfin c'est
comme ça que je vois les choses quoi il
a fait une belle partie contre Manu
s'ils doivent être très content hier il
y a pas de raison qui s'arrête pour moi
le riz je sais pas ce que tu en penses
mais
j'y crois pas j'y crois pas une
proposition de nulle un peu caché j'y
crois pas
ok ok donc
[Musique]
sur ce qui force
j'attends de voir j'attends de voir j'ai
pas vu les parties hier je t'avoue j'ai
une grosse journée j'ai même pas vu le
replay mais pas donc je sais pas trop
comment ça s'est passé
est-ce qu'on fait les joueurs
alors excuse-moi je ne t'ai même pas
écouté j'étais j'étais pris d'un fou
rire quand François-Jacques me dit dans
le chat désolé Kevin mais je suis un
breton avec une technique très
sophistiquée
je sais pas je sais pas Françoise on est
tous cachés derrière des pseudos twitch
mais est-ce que tu bluffes est-ce que tu
bluffes ou tu confirmes vraiment quoi
alors il excuse-moi je t'ai coupé est-ce
que tu voulais bien me redire ce que ce
que tu avais dit Lorie
ah tu veux pas mince c'est terrible à
regarder le replay
c'est terrible non après j'ai juste vu
la variante chouchen de Pola X et ça m'a
fait rigoler du coup j'étais pas
concentré quoi j'étais pas concentré
de choses comme ça dans le chat c'est
terrible pour moi oui
exactement ils sont malins ils
détournent mon attention parlant de la
Bretagne tu sais très bien probreton
voilà donc c'est sûrement en retard
c'est
c'est la seule
je voulais sa cam tout à l'heure je l'ai
pas encore eu on l'a redemandra à
Vanessa puisque maintenant elle m'a mis
le multicam je pense qu'elle trouvait un
peu bizarre que je demande la cam ou
Magnus n'est pas là
voilà donc elle m'a mis un petit câble
il y a un roulement du coup des caméras
alors si tu veux il y a plusieurs
caméras mais aujourd'hui je ne légère
pas il y a ce qu'on appelle le multicam
ça va tourner justement comme un
carrousel au niveau des caméras ou alors
tu peux dédier si je m'étais occupé du
stream ben je pouvais changer
manuellement à chaque fois comme le
faisait souff il avait son papier tu
vois j'avais pris en fait j'avais tous
les tuyaux de stouffe donc j'avais prévu
mon petit papier avec les caméras mais
du coup bah comme je ne gère pas le
stream bah forcément j'en ai pas eu
besoin
demain c'est moi qui gère le stream pour
la première fois pour la dernière ronde
ça va être le véritable feu d'artifice
potentiellement si ça ne marche pas on
saura pourquoi maintenant
voilà soufflés c'est pas mal ce que tu
as dit là-dessus donc on continue pour
cette partie il faut prendre ces 5 dames
prendre les 8 Abdou il se laisse manger
la dame parce que le roi en fait il
trouve une cage sans E7 quand les dames
sont échangées on parle d'un milieu de
jeu sont les dames il y a que les dames
d'échanger les deux pions mais il faut
bien dire que dans ces milieux de jeu
sont les dames Fatou le roi ne craint
pas grand chose au sandales ça il faut
vraiment jauger alors c'est pour ça que
les débutants on va pas conseiller
pendant ça notamment de se dévoquer si
rapidement ok là par contre
après un échange de dames dans certaines
positions aussi on peut voir que le roi
est
il est un peu dans les dans les starting
blocks pour la finale il va commencer à
se placer à rester un peu
plus centralisé plus avancé mais sans
être en danger pour autant donc là c'est
ce qui se passe ici exactement on voit
que très rapidement donc il y a eu deux
parce qu'à moins il y aura B5 donc je
vais être préventif roi E7 et comme nous
dit Fatou ben il n'y a pas d'accès de
toute façon sur le roi et elle nous
parle un peu de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la préfinale aux échecs c'est
juste avant la finale et Fatou nous
explique que le roi noir est placé pour
la finale c'est une très très bonne
explication et du coup on n'a pas
l'impression que les Noirs soient
inquiétés en pratique c'est un petit peu
différent il y a quand même une avance
de développement pour les blancs faire
valider les deux jouets
des 7 pourquoi pas on doit se développer
avec des Noirs c'est l'urgence B3 on
pourrait très vite voir fou B2 pour C1
attaquer le fou et si je le recul
bêtement je me peux me prendre des fois
trois et commencer à être gêné au niveau
du roi tout petit plus d'activités des
pièces avec
avec les pièces blanches est-ce que ça
va suffire normalement ce sont quand
même des variantes inoffensives comme tu
nous lisais un petit peu à demi-mot au
départ enfin tout voilà donc c'est pour
ça
tout à fait raison et il y a pas les
dames
bon bah on a bien expliqué toute cette
théorie autour du candidat m'a accepté
et Magnus nous semble en retard donc bon
je pense que si on demande la caméra de
Magnus on aura juste
le fauteuil donc j'ai pas demandé le
fauteuil de Magnus
c'est un petit peu étonnant dans ce type
de tournoi
dans certains tournois de haut niveau il
peut y avoir ce qu'on appelle les
tolérances 0 c'est-à-dire que vous
n'êtes pas là en début de ronde
c'est sanctionné directement par
l'arbitre d'une bulle d'une défaite dans
ce type de gros gros tournoi bon ils
vont pas mettre ça au joueur de très
haut niveau
je ne connais pas la règle c'était pas
prévu qu'un joueur fasse forfait et ce
serait étonnant que Manu ça n'arrive pas
d'ici quelques minutes
voilà ça c'est pas mal
autant pour moi Magnus ne risque pas
de pertes français ah bah voilà alors je
ne sais pas il a dû arriver en retard
c'est certain parce que la partie la
partie a mis longtemps à se charger mais
en tout cas vous voilà rassurer on a la
cam de Magnus voilà et on va pouvoir
voir son déburytique quelqu'un l'avait
mis dans le chat je pense que c'est
Néandertal vous voulez me le dire tout à
l'heure et
et j'ai pas compris Néandertal voilà
donc du coup cavalier 3 cavalier F6 pour
l'instant il se passe rien c'est le
début des vieux briscard cavalier F3 on
ne dit pas trop quelle ouverture on va
jouer ça peut tomber sur un coup comme
C5 on peut retomber si on veut dans une
chienne on peut jouer avec des systèmes
anglais ces 4 G3 on peut encore jouer D4
prochainement ça dépend cavalier F6 C4
et là on est bien parti c'est une
Anglaise symétrique voilà ces cartes C5
on a rajouté des cavaliers position
archi symétrique et ce qui est assez
rigolo c'est qu'on va voir la technique
du miroir employée par pragnananda c'est
plutôt les joueurs débutants ou début
d'un amateur qui essaient de faire ça
pour
reproduire le bon développement de
l'adversaire
attention l'ordre de prise ou d'échec le
miroir se brise Fatou et les journaux
c'est ça le miroir c'est limite c'est
bien dit
donc E3 et on va essayer de jouer pour
des 4 donc E6 voilà rien de miroir de
chez miroir C4 D5 très rare quand même
de voir ce genre de l'histoire
et là il va se passer quelque chose de
très rigolo il y a eu à 3
des Français 4 français 4
est-ce que ça vous dit quelque chose
est-ce que Fatou ça te dit quelque chose
[Musique]
vous me dites c'est le compte n'est pas
bon mais pour moi il a perdu trois mugs
Laurent
et oui
et oui oui
ce temps non plus
Pascal vous avez commencé à sentir
l'astuce et toi est-ce que tu voyais ce
que je voulais dire
j'ai pas regardé ce que tu voulais dire
qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire et ben
regarde ça me ressemble étrangement à
tout à l'heure alors c'était pas du tout
le même début c'était un miroir là un
miroir sans nom une anglais
on est vraiment dans une structure très
approchante
de cette position voilà qui est un
gambidame accepté donc vous voyez que
par des ordres de coups différents on
peut arriver dans les mêmes les mêmes
positions voilà alors ça
botte c'est arrivé hier par moment c'est
très rare mais
elle a des connexions un peu plus
fluctuantes et comme c'est elle qui gère
le stream ben vous voyez bien la
problématique
voilà donc le retour on est de retour je
pense
voilà c'est ce que le chat a entendu les
explications
alors je ne sais pas en tout cas on a
perdu même la cam la cam de la salle de
jeux ou Magnus est bien arrivé mais ça y
est on est en train de retrouver et du
coup ben on est dans la même structure
donc Vanessa d'ailleurs elle a vu la vue
qu'on était sur Abdou et Wesley Sow et
elle nous a mis à la cam mais on voulait
juste expliquer la structure de pion le
riz finalement c'est la même structure
d'options dans l'ouverture miroir en
glace symétrique de pragnananda et dans
ce gamin accepté d'addousa torov voilà
ce qu'on peut remarquer et après ça va
changer puisque
même squelette exactement le même
squelette voilà
il y a même eu ce qui a 6 par contre ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que
là on voit que que manus n'a pas joué
pour les dépenses et 5 il a joué entre
guillemets pour la pseudo vérité de la
position c'est-à-dire le pion isolé donc
il a joué fou des trois ici préventif de
V5 voilà bon B5 peut être joué quand
même dans certains sens
et la structure typique puisque les
Blancs n'ont pas pris en C5 c'est le
noir qui prennent
et on arrive dans ce pion isolé avec le
pion des 4 emprise voilà mais Magnus il
a forcément vu ça Laurie il a pas donné
un pion à son adversaire je pense que ça
il s'est calculé exactement il n'a pas
donné on peut regarder un Laurent il
aimait bien bouger les pièces moi il y a
pas trop le droit on doit calculer comme
nous dit Lorie au moins des suites deux
couches chacun ça ferait 4 demi coups
c'est pas mal si vous arrivez à ça c'est
encore mieux de calculer trois coups à
l'avance trois couches chacun mais si
demi-cou j'ai remarqué pour les joueurs
amateurs ça commence à devenir difficile
tout dépend de votre niveau mais déjà
essayez quand vous faites des exercices
de tactiques à la maison sur des sites
comme chaise.com faites les efforts
d'essayer d'anticiper de pas jouer tout
le temps avec la mimine
voilà les mains dans le dos vous asseyez
sur vos mains il y a plusieurs façons de
le dire mais en tout cas voilà faut
faire les efforts c'est vrai que la
dernière fois que je t'avais vu en
tournoi Lorie tu étais en déplacement
avec toute la délégation du Mans les
Manceaux étaient en colo tournoi au
festival de Saint-Lô et tu t'occupais de
beaucoup de jeunes enfants est-ce que tu
veux en parler un petit peu de ce que tu
faisais pendant ce tournoi d'ailleurs
Lorie le petit colonie en parallèle
justement je me suis fait d'ailleurs
héberger par recueillir par évolution
échec le premier midi parce que j'exé
exactement moi c'est vrai c'est vrai de
ta colo tu avais abandonné mais du coup
tu gérais avec donc Christophe de la
Fontaine Florian Bouvet donc deux
joueurs d'échec bien connu au niveau du
club du Mans tu gérais une ribambelle
dans de jeunes joueurs d'échec voilà et
vous les gériez sur le sur le plan
quotidien on va dire et aussi sur
l'entraînement aux échecs c'est ça et
une autre animatrice aussi la Californie
donc d'accord c'est vrai que je l'ai vu
mais en fait je la connaissais pas et je
pensais que c'était une maman en fait
dans des jeunes aussi c'est aussi
c'est super donc voilà les colonies donc
c'est très bien alors pour ceux qui nous
regardent les parents qui nous regardent
c'est très bien d'envoyer vos enfants
s'ils sont passionnés d'échecs en colo
l'été bah parce que au travail et eux ça
va leur plaire c'est vraiment
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner et
auprès de vos clubs des chèques ou
auprès de de structures il y en a
plusieurs donc chez pré-évolution on en
propose mais il y en a d'autres donc
n'hésitez pas à regarder par rapport à
vos différentes contraintes ce qui
existe et ça peut vraiment plaire allez
on continue avec un coup ici marginal G6
alors je le comprends le riz pourquoi
est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer
pourquoi G6
on sait que c'est pour passer le coup en
G7 donc faire un petit chien
on peut se poser la question parce que
peut-être que le four et puis sortir sur
l'autre diagonale
et après bien sûr on a on a notre cible
notre grande cible avec les Noirs ça va
être ce pion isolé c'est pour ça que
Prague joue ça aimer son coup
directement G7 ça a du sens par contre
c'est un peu lent
oui c'est souvent le problème alors là
l'idée quand on a un pion comme ça isolé
il faut réussir donc avec la couleur
opposée a le bloquer pas qu'il avance
pour pas qu'il puisse s'échanger et
réussir à mettre toutes nos pièces
dessus le viser petit à petit mais c'est
souvent long tout à fait le riz c'est
vrai qu'on a expliqué on rappelle contre
le pion isolé adverse se développer
bloquer pressé voilà le principe même
maintenant vague les blancs ça va être
la remarque un peu inverse on veut pas
qu'un jeu long terme s'établisse
on n'a pas envie de subir toute la
partie ben cette faiblesse donc on va
essayer de s'engager dans la voie de
l'initiative avec un placement de pièces
ambitieux et si Laurie veut bloquer mon
pion ici en D4 avec les Blancs vous
l'avez vu hier dans la partie qu'on a
commenté avec Laurent sur ce même sujet
du pion isolé c'était la partie de
Magnus contre Wesley sceaux une lime ou
indienne on veut faire des cinq on veut
faire des cinq regardez Magnus il
emploie le 5 ou G7 et le très joli ou E4
avec l'idée vraisemblablement à terme de
faire quelque chose pour des cinq
petites très joli parce que c'est pas
très naturel en fait c'est un petit peu
atypique de positionnement du fond en E4
par contre on comprend l'idée le fou il
a quand même sacrément circulaire il a
pris en Sacca après il est revenu on dit
voyez au joueur amateur et débutants
faut pas bouger trop de fois la même
pièce dans le début pour cette constater
que les joueurs de haut niveau
des fois prennent quelques largesses par
rapport aux règles générales il y a des
exceptions Magnus considère qu'il est
bien mieux développé que l'adversaire et
qu'il peut mettre la pression sur le
joueur adverse même en bougeant
plusieurs fois son foulards
il sait exactement où il va il a un plan
précis donc effectivement même si la
première vue ça fait ça fait des petits
aller-retours exactement alors est-ce
qu'il voudrait déjà faire des cinq
prochainement pourquoi pas on a envie
de mettre comme le roi à l'abri mais
voilà les idées des 5 il y aurait
peut-être aussi pourquoi pas des
cavaliers 5 pour l'instant pion s'enlève
à titre perso pour le moment j'ai pas
trop envie de prononcé 6 parce que même
si je crée le pion isolé en C6 j'ai plus
jamais des S5 donc mon pion sera
vraiment lui aussi isolé voilà faut
quand même regarder toutes ces histoires
de changement de structure de pions
alors tu m'as était une spécialiste
squelette d'option laurier est-ce que tu
pourrais m'en dire plus
non on peut parler les pions aux échecs
en fait c'est comme c'est comme un
squelette c'est vraiment très important
donc à première vue c'est rien on
échange des pièces on échange des pions
en fait les pions c'est plus important
parce que toute la position peut changer
selon la structure de pion vous imaginez
le squelette parce que c'est un peu
comme une fracture aussi on le voit par
exemple quand on balance tout sur le roi
inverse on essaie de faire des des trous
avec les pions et donc de fracturer le
squelette du roi adverse parce qu'elle
est adverse au roi donc oui là ça ferait
des pions isolés comme il dit je suis
isolé on n'est pas on n'est pas trop ça
ça fait une cible mais il faut voir les
cils aussi que ça crée chez l'adversaire
avec ce python des qui aussi isolé le
pion B là pour le moment arriéré et
qu'il va être aussi peut-être une cible
donc faut voir tout savoir tout ce qui
change quand il y a des échanges de de
structures quand les pions bougent dans
une position
tout recalculer la position en fait
est-ce que j'ai bien
c'était parfait en plus ça m'a permis de
répondre le Rivier à une question dans
le chat quelqu'un cherchait un club sur
Toulouse
c'était sous Livan et du coup je vous ai
remis on a souvent ce type de question
de joueurs Laurie qui cherche des clubs
par chez eux parce qu'il faut savoir que
la plupart des il y a quand même
énormément de gens qui nous regardent
qui qui ont pas encore franchi la porte
d'un club exactement donc si vous voulez
taper à la porte je vous ai mis le lien
du site fédéral qui vous permet de
devoir tous les clubs officiels qui
existent en France donc il y en a
sûrement près de chez vous si vous êtes
vraiment passionné d'échec si vous avez
envie de progresser je pense qu'on peut
pas vous donner le meilleur conseil que
de jouer donc de jouer des parties
officielles donc de vous inscrire en
club il y en a qui osent pas trop départ
en disant ben non je suis pas assez fort
c'est sans doute pas faux que évidemment
des efforts au départ vous n'aurez pas
la même expérience que les joueurs qui
sont depuis des années en club ça ne
vous empêche pas de vous épanouir dans
la discipline je vous rappelle que je
fais du soccer du badminton des choses
que j'ai démarré sur le tard et du coup
je suis débutant ou amateur on va dire
mais en tout cas j'ai vraiment pas 2450
en badminton même si je barre robinsight
quand même faut pas exagérer
de cause je vous invite à aller en club
si vous êtes vraiment passionné jouer
sur internet en plus mais allez en club
allez en club tu fais du sport un petit
peu Lorient en plus ou pas
tu fais du foot
tous les tournages j'ai toujours mon
ballon avec moi donc ouais
autour de Saint-Lô avec avec les gars
enfin quand il y avait l'équipe etc
c'est pas impossible c'est pas
impossible mais je les appelle j'avais
zappé ok bah foot mais pas ce cœur c'est
foot à 11 c'est ça c'est ça
[Musique]
pas mal de jours d'échecs qui ont dans
le sud aussi leur petit réseau de
stockage
Sébastien est mazazé et Mathieu cornet
qui jouait dans la même équipe ça doit
être une équipe de soccer assez modeste
mais il jouait quand même dans dans la
même équipe et d'ailleurs Mathieu pourra
sans doute nous en parler on en parlera
demain c'est important que je vois si
Mathieu a toujours ses problèmes au
Chili parce qu'il était sujet à des
blessures récurrentes c'est un très fort
grand maître aux échecs mais d'un point
de vue sportif vous pouvez largement
rivaliser au soccer avec Mathieu j'en
suis certain en tout cas demain on en
parlera avec lui je pense qu'il y aura
envie de se défendre si je le titille un
peu comme cela il va sûrement nous dire
et puis bon vous savez après il y a la
vie perso aussi donc faire du soccer
c'est un plaisir mais c'est pas toujours
possible qu'on a beaucoup de contraintes
donc Mathieu nous en parlera demain ça
sera le dernier invité pour la dernière
ronde ça me permet
parler Prague qui est à l'écran voilà et
du coup
on voit qu'il est gêné par ce fou E4 en
tout cas il est en pleine réflexion il
faut 4 c'est un coup assez assez
compromettant
ce qui est marrant c'est que ça montre
un plan très clair que du coup c'est la
poussée
est-ce qu'on
l'envisage ça après ce qui va prendre
aussi le cavalier mais ça je crois
j'y crois moyen en fait à un moment on
pourrait peut-être jouer des cinq
prenons F6 jouer sur casse blanche en
tout cas voilà
et il y a plusieurs
plusieurs positions analysées
un petit roc à l'air assez logique dans
ce genre de position
il va falloir en tout cas oui mais il
faut 4 c'est aussi c'est un coup de
stabilisation c'est à dire que tu as du
mal avec ton fossé 8 et tu peux pas
jouer B6 ou B7
c'est bizarre j'ai quand même du mal
pour l'instant Magnus il appuie juste
aussi sur le fait
de mettre en place un jeu de restriction
c'est à dire un fou de merde il y a pas
de mots il dit ça après il est en train
de lui dire un fou de merde tu le gardes
ton fou de merde toute la partie vous
savez que Magnus en ouverture préférée
c'est la Catalane mais il adore mettre
son fond en fiancéto BIM et domine le
fouet 8 là dans un autre registre Fatou
il est en train il est vraiment en train
de profiter de cela le soccer pour ceux
qui ne savent pas c'est du foot en 4 + 1
ça ressemble plus au foot salle
comment t'expliquerait c'est toi la
chose de foot en fait moi je suis genre
de faute du dimanche
c'est les papas de l'école maternelle
moyenne d'âge 35-40 ans
et on va jouer des petits jeunes qui ont
20 25 ans puisque là du soccer quand
même sur trois divisions voilà sans me
vanter évidemment vous l'aurez bien
compris mais on remonte on remonte ça y
est dernière match de la saison
ce mardi pour ceux qui veulent nous voir
au soccer de La Mézière voilà je pense
qu'il y aura beaucoup de monde il y aura
beaucoup de spectateurs une nouvelle
fois
en fait ce qui est bien c'est qu'il y a
deux saisons une année voilà donc
ok c'est top et donc le soccer fout en
cas de plus un sur des petits terrains
en gazon synthé voilà en salle voilà
voilà est-ce qu'on peut pas découle le
cavalier viser le flou blanc